good morning everyone welcome to the
Commission's press room for a press
conference with the Commissioner for
trade Gil Hogan who will talk to you
about the decisions taken by the
Commission to make sure that Europe's
interests are defended when it comes to
international trade without further ado
commissioner the floor is yours thank
you very much Daniel ladies and
gentlemen welcome to this morning's
press briefing this is my first press
briefing as EU commissioner for trade
and I'm pleased to be able to announce
that the Commission is today responding
directly to the paralysis of the WTO
appellate body by proposing important
changes to the EU enforcement regulation
this measure ensures that the European
Union will continue to protect itself
effectively against any third countries
that had ups illegal trade practices and
simultaneously blocks the dispute
settlement process both in the context
of the WTO and the implementation of
bilateral agreements the proposed
changes will allow the European Union to
take protective action in defense of its
citizens and its businesses in the event
that a country is found to be in breach
of the WTO rules and divides compliance
by blocking the WTO dispute settlement
passes under the current enforcement
regulation the you can only introduce
countermeasures based on a final and
binding WTO decision however following
yesterday's development in the WTO where
its members are now able to avoid a
binding WTO decision completely since
the WTO upended body which is the
highest instance to adjudicate and trade
disputes is no longer able to take
decisions and this is very regrettable
and a very serious blow to the
international rules based trading system
which for the past 24 years has relied
on the WTO as a pellet body and dispute
settlement generally as a result of the
u.s. blocking the continuation of this
appellate body the absence of an
effective dispute settlement mechanism
creates a significant gap in the EU with
legislation and can put at risk
this be was enforcement ability and
endanger the EU was interest
and when the European Union has the
right of action under an international
agreement but Kennison forces
effectively and in an timely manner the
II was economic interests are left
unprotected so it is unacceptable that
the EU cannot enforce its rights through
adjudication the blockage in the dispute
settlement mechanisms could even create
an incentive for countries to thwart
adjudication when the European Union has
rights under the inch under an
international agreement which the 12
country has infringe to any WTO member
can simply unknowingly appeal on
favorable First Instance WTO panel
decisions into the void to an appellate
body which is unable to take decisions
so we have proposed amendments to the
enforcement regulation to address this
situation these amendments would allow
the European Union to impose
countermeasures if the WTO panel finds
in the first instance that another WTO
member hands the European Union through
a breach of the WTO rules and secondly
the losing party appeals against the
decision to the appellate body with the
aim of preventing the case from
conclusion and has not agreed to an
interim arrangement for an appeal to
happen these changes seek to respect and
protect community or rules and
procedures instead of going around them
and therefore reaffirms the EU support
for the WTO moreover our actions today
are fully compatible with international
public law we believe in the European
Union in a functioning WTO organisation
and we will continue to seek to resolve
our disputes within that system as a
further response to the paralysis of the
appellate body the European Union has
proposed an alternative interim
arrangement for Appeal or arbitration on
the WTO rules which provides the
possibility of an appeal today is a
small number of trading partners such as
Canada and Norway have joined this
arrangement with us and we are talking
to others and in effect today we're
introducing a further line of defence we
still have the WTO panels whose
decisions can become binding if none of
the parties appeal against them we have
an alternative interim arrangement to
decide on Appeals for partners to who
accept it when the appellate party is
not functioning and we now also have the
possibility to take
measures based on the WTO panel
decisions in the event that other
countries prevent either of those two
scenarios from playing out enforcing the
European Union's rights in international
trade as a key priority of the von der
Leyen Commission and the European Union
will not only increase its focus on
enforcing its partners commitments on
the WTO but also in regional and
bilateral trade agreements when third
countries do not comply with their
obligations on their bilateral dispute
settlement arrangements the enforcement
regulation is one of the instruments
through which we will do that now
becoming even stronger to our proposed
amendments which I've just mentioned in
addition to the enforcement regulation
EU would trade defense rules also permit
us to avoid dumped our subsidized
imports threatening the EU s economy
even since the beginning of this month's
months since they took office we have
adopted a number of threat defense
measures against China and we will adopt
more shortly finally weíll also shortly
appointed chief trade enforcement
officer to strengthen our work on
compliance and enforcement further all
of this sends a clear signal that a
strong Europe in the world means also a
strong Europe in global trade trade
disputes so I hope that the council and
the Parliament can adopt the amendment
to the enforcement regulation as a
matter of urgency so that we're fully
prepared to protect the EU whose
interests in this rapidly changing world
of international trade thank you before
to your questions just to let you know
that the press